- Another banger from the
Twitter account Bad Legal Takes.
Someone from ABC was
asking to use a video clip
that was taken on a plane.
To which another person
helpfully responds,
"Them asking was a formality.
Once you post something
on the internet, it's out
there for the world to see
and use as they please,
without having to pay
or ask for your
authorization to use legally,
they just have to credit the person
who recorded and posted."
No! Agh!
Look, this is a common
misconception about copyright law,
but it is very, very wrong.
When things enter the public domain,
yes, you can use them for any purpose.
But for something to
enter the public domain,
they basically need to have
their copyright term expired.
That generally means they have
to be 100 or 120 years old.
Just because something
is public doesn't mean
it's in the public domain.
Just because something is on the internet,
doesn't mean you can use it
for whatever reason you want.
Don't do that.
If you use stuff that's on the internet
without getting the proper
rights, I will see you in court.